a court in hong kong has found seven
prominent pro-democracy activists guilty
for their role in a 2019 protest
prosecutors say the demonstration was
unauthorized
those convicted include a media tycoon
former legislators
and the man who's considered to be hong
kong's father of democracy
two others had pleaded guilty before the
verdict critics say that all this
is part of a crackdown on dissent which
escalated
after china imposed a national security
law in hong kong
last year let's go live now to hong kong
al jazeera sarah clark
is outside the courthouse sarah talk us
through
these verdicts who's been convicted what
happened in court
well the verdict has been handed down in
the last hour or so and these are some
of the most high-profile
veteran pro-democracy activists and
campaigners
in hong kong now as you mentioned seven
and this group of nine pleaded not
guilty but they have been found
guilty anyway they've been convicted and
in that group probably some of the most
high-profile
activists as i mentioned we've got
73-year-old media tycoon
jimmy ly he's well known for his
pro-democracy stance through his
media group next media media and his
apple daily uh media outlets we've got
82 year old
martin lee he's a highly respected
barrister he's also the man considered
the father of democracy he also has been
found guilty
we've got 73 year old respected
barrister and former legislator margaret
un
as well as lee chuk yen he's the man
who's been holding the tiananmen square
visible
for decades here in hong kong he also
has been found guilty
two of the others in this particular
group are they have previously uh
pleaded guilty therefore they too have
been convicted
i spoke to a number of those uh the
members of this particular group on
arrival
at court at the west caroline court uh
today on thursday
martin lee said he's prepared to go to
jail to fight for democracy
and the freedoms that were promised uh
to this former british territory
i also spoke to lee chuk yan and this is
what he had to say on his way into court
in this day of reckoning
the political suppression is equally to
all
those who have take part in the protest
movement including
no matter where you are the peaceful no
knowledge or the braver
you are all caught under this political
suppression way
so they've been convicted if this group
gets sent to
prison where does this leave hong kong's
pro-democracy movement
well it certainly is a blow to the
movement uh nearly every
major voice or or of dissent or figure
of opposition is now either in exile
in jail already or on trial now more
than 2
400 people have been charged as part of
this crackdown
at the likes of jimmy ly the media
tycoon who i spoke about earlier he's
currently
in custody he's also facing six other
trials
one of those under the national security
law we also have league chucky and he's
facing
three different trials uh they're
separate charges but separate but
similar charges i should say
uh so certainly this particular
pro-democracy movement uh it's a blow to
it
uh the the movement says that this is
the national security law
is beijing's attempt to crack down or
silence the opposition
in hong kong another veteran activist i
spoke to on the way into court she said
the movement will simply have to find
other ways of showing the opposition to
china
and fighting for the freedoms in hong
kong that were promised at the 1997
agreement
al jazeera sarah clark reporting live
from hong kong sarah many thanks